and I've gotten in a bad thing and I
just wasn't trusting anybody
and Rogan was like yeah man we're trying
to be your [__] friend and I was like
yeah I don't I don't need friends
I couldn't understand what why Rogan was
interested in me and I said to like
someone was like is he gay like
what the [__] yeah and then he was just
a nice guy he was just a nice guy
that'd be hilarious if Joe was sexually
attracted to you this whole time this
whole time is the reason he keeps
inviting about I would be more excited I
would be more excited if just if he
tried to kiss me on the lips once just
and just and then like in a Scotty
Scotty J way from Boogie Nights where
he's like what do you like my car yeah
you know nobody would believe that story
no one yeah if I was Joe I would kiss
dudes all the time and then be like and
then and then when they didn't kiss back
oh you know never no one ever believe
you